[Music]
well this daily cancellation ends up
working out pretty well because uh given
the news of the day it's all about
babies and uh why babies are good and
why you should have them but it begins
with not with roe v wade but with a
writer for the atlantic as we know
writers for the atlantic are not the
most perceptive or insightful bunch as a
rule and that rule seems to hold true
for atlantic writer olga kazan who
tweeted recently quote
i'm still curious how women are supposed
to have kids before they're 35 if they
make 40 000 a year before they're 35 and
child care is 40 000
now the tweet has resonated enough to
earn nearly 80 000 likes with lots of
people in the comments chiming in to
agree that it's essentially impossible
for a woman to have kids under the age
of 35 unless she earns substantially
more than the average income for that
age bracket
and yet shockingly it turns out that um
you know many women have done exactly
this in fact through history literally
billions of women have this is one of
the curious features of modern american
life american life that
people are constantly proclaiming it
impossible to do the things which
billions of other people have already
done and are currently doing
so we can look around and see billions
of people doing something and then say
it's not possible okay that's impossible
no one can do it except for these 10
billion people
this is because most of the time
when we say that we cannot do something
the sentence is incomplete
we haven't really finished the thought
what we meant to say is that we cannot
do said thing
while still maintaining the comfort and
luxury that we've come to expect and
demand
we cannot do it easily we cannot do it
without effort
we cannot do it while um staying true to
our undying principle that we should
never have to make any personal
sacrifices of any kind
we cannot do it without getting off the
couch etc
one of these caveats or similar to it
usually silently accompanies our
declarations about what we cannot do and
that's certainly the case here
but olga is not alone far from it as
people put off having children more and
more putting it off so long that
eventually it becomes a physical
impossibility in reality to have kids at
least without the help of a petri dish
in a science lab
the reason often given by by people who
put it off is that it's not financially
feasible to have kids
and this fear is encouraged by random
fake statistics pulled out of thin air
like the statistic that child care costs
40 grand a year
putting your kid in child care in
daycare says olga is as expensive
as a really expensive private school
now fortunately this is not remotely
true
in fact the most expensive the most
expensive state for daycare is
massachusetts on average and there it
costs an average of twenty thousand
dollars a year uh to get daycare which
is absurdly high but it's half of olga's
estimate
but if you live in most other states
you're paying under 15. in many states
the average is under 10 000 a year in a
state like mississippi it's half that
now there are of course many other
fictional horror stories about the cost
of having children many of them coming
from alleged authority figures more
prominent than olga on twitter the usda
for example put out a report last year
claiming that the average child costs 15
000 a year
and this means that a family of three if
you do the math is forking over 45 grand
a year just to keep their kids alive
i'm supposedly spending 60 000 a year
just on my kids
that works out to um about 270 000 per
child to get them from age zero to age
18. then if you have four kids four or
five of them you know like i do then
you're you're in the hole for a million
plus
i mean you got to be a millionaire to
have kids
now admittedly with with biden's
inflation it's starting to actually feel
like you need to be a millionaire to
afford groceries and gasoline even just
for yourself but on average assuming
that hopefully the current trends don't
hold for the next 18 years
these figures are nonsense
it is certainly possible
possible
to spend 15 grand in a year on one child
i mean you could do that you could spend
triple that if you wanted to
yet there's no law of nature requiring
that kind of financial investment
if there was then billions of people who
have kids now and who've had them in the
past would not have been able to survive
and yet they did and they do
the consequence of this way of thinking
believing that you need to have massive
amounts of money in the bank just to
afford even one kid is that as mentioned
people put off starting families later
and later
you know we think that we should get
through young adulthood establish
ourselves build a life of some
some sort and then finally begin the
process of finding spouses and becoming
parents once we're safely ensconced in
the protective cocoon of middle age
that's what we think
speaking of finding a spouse notice how
olga never accounts for marriage at all
it would cost a woman 40 grand a year
for child care she says
but if you're doing it right the cost
which definitely will not be 40 grand is
shared by a woman and a man together in
the bond of marriage
we've been conditioned to see these
things on an individualized basis
we think that you know a man should make
a life for himself all alone
and then inject a wife and kids into
this thing that's already been
constructed without them
like set it all up and then introduce
the family
and this strategy leads to a lot of its
own problems
the man will often begin to resent his
family because they're intruding
this is not their life it's his
he can't look to his wife and kids and
say well they were here with with me
when i had nothing we were together from
the beginning we we climbed to this
point together rather he looks at them
and says i built this on my own i did
all this on by myself i climbed without
them this is mine
they don't know anything about it the
free loaders
i think this is probably one of the
reasons why people who get married in
their 30s have higher divorce rates
because they've already established
their own things and get very possessive
of their own thing their own life that
they've made for themselves
walking the bumpiest parts of the road
together
struggling sacrificing suffering going
without
together this is what brings a family
together
that's why as i've always said
i think it's better to see marriage and
family as the cornerstone of adult life
rather than the capstone
in modern times we tend to favor the
capstone model we say that a young adult
should live through
young adulthood by himself save money
get all of his affairs in order and then
as the culmination as the at the
conclusion of this process as he enters
middle age then he should commence with
getting married and having kids
that way he'll be able to quote unquote
afford it
but the cornerstone approach on the
other hand says that it's better to
start your family at the beginning of
the process not at the end
build your adult life with your spouse
and children have them there at the
foundation of it all bring them in on
the ground floor so to speak
this is how nearly every culture in the
world has approached this issue until
ours
we flip this well-worn battle-tested
model on its head and tried it the
reverse way and it really doesn't seem
to be working
the result has been higher divorce rates
lower marriage rates people are less
satisfied in life not as happy
population
populations are declining and to top it
all off the people who hold off on
having families for financial reasons
very often discover as mentioned that
they they they never reach a point where
they feel financially ready not at 25
not at 30 not at 35.
they sit around waiting for the dollars
and cents to add up while their
biological clocks tick away
until finally it'll cost them like
twenty thousand dollars in an ivf clinic
simply to conceive a child when they
could have done it for free
and in a way that's a lot more fun by
the way
just a few years before that
this is supposed to be the financially
conscious approach which really doesn't
make a lot of sense when you think about
it
and that's why olga at the atlantic
is today cancelled but even more than
olga the atlantic
as you might have already heard row is
cancelled stay tuned
as the supreme court i think has issued
the greatest daily cancellation of all
time
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really as that's what
it is we're joy we're forming a cult
then all you got to do is click the
subscribe button and ring the bell below
this video to stay up to date with all
my content and if you want even more you
can watch or listen to my show at
thedailywire.com spotify or apple
podcast looking forward to welcoming you
to the sweet baby gang
you